So for all that DNA to fit in a cell, the two main ways to it's organized
are first by compaction, meaning organization by proteins
called histones. Let's zoom out a bit on our
DNA strand and imagine our double stranded DNA
is just this one purple line. The first order
of organization is that DNA is going to
wrap around these histone proteins. Much like you might
wrap string in a spool and you can see that it just wraps around and around
and around. And this allows for some basic
organization, in the same way that loose string in
a drawer or your pocket has a tendency to get tangled. If you wrap it around an
object to keep it steady Then it can't
get tangled as easily, and that's the same principle
that's going on here for organization. The
second way DNA is organized to fit inside
a cell is that it's split into
units called chromosomes, which are large collections of
this histone-wrapped DNA. You've probably seen pictures
of chromosomes before. They're usually these long, large,
linear pieces of DNA in histones called
chromatin. If you're not sure if you've seen
a chromsone, then you've probably seen something that looks
like this, like an X. This is also considered
a chromosone. And both of these sturcutres are just
this compacted DNA wrapped around histones. Such that we could
zoom in on the chromosome here. Just a very
small region, and this is what we would see. And
teh same that if we zoomed in here, on
the DNA strand, this is what we would see here,
teh edoubl helix.